very happy to be joining you and good
local time everyone so that's about them
sorry to tell us about digital tools and
and covin sure yeah I'm really happy to
share with you how I tell has
successfully countered the COBIT using
the power of Digital democracy tools and
as we know democracy improves as more
people participate and digital
technology remains one of the best ways
to improve participation as long as the
focus is on finding common ground that
is to say Pro social media instead of
anti social media and there's three key
ideas that I would like to share today
about there's democracy that is fast
fair and fun first about a fast part
whereas many jurisdictions began
countering coronavirus only this year
how I started last year last December
when dr. Leigh Whannell the PRC
whistleblower posted at their new stars
cases he got inquiries and eventually
punishments from PRC police institutions
but at the same time that how an
equivalent of Reddit the PTT board has
someone called no more pipe reposting
dr. Lee will announce whistleblowing in
our medical officers immediately noticed
this post and issue and ordered assess
all passengers flying in from Wuhan to
Taiwan the two started health inspection
the very next day which is the first day
of January and this says to me two
things first a civil society trust that
govern enough to talk about possible new
source outbreaks in the public forum and
the government trusts citizens enough to
take it seriously and treat it as if
stars has happen again something we've
always been preparing since 2003 and
because of this open civil society
according to the Civic is monitor after
the sunflower occupy Taiwan is now the
most open society in the whole of Asia
we enjoy the same freedom speech of
assembly the president's the one as
other liberal democracies but with the
emphasis on keeping an open mind to
novel ideas
from the society and that is why our
schools and businesses still remain open
today there was no lockdowns it's been a
month with no local confirmed cases so
the fast part every day our central
epidemic come on Sansa was the ECC held
a press conference which is always live
streamed and we work with the
journalists they answer all the
questions from the journalists and
whenever there's new idea coming in from
the social sector anyone can pick up
their phone and call 192 until that idea
to the cec see for example there was one
day in April where a young boy does that
he doesn't want to go to school because
their school may may laugh at him
because all he had is pink medical mask
the very next day everybody in the CDC
press conference started wearing pink
medical mask making sure that everybody
learns about gender mainstreaming and so
this kind of Rapid Response system
builds trust between the government and
the civil society and the second focus
is fairness making sure everybody can
use their national health insurance card
to collect masks for nearby pharmacies
not only do we publish the stock level
of masks of all pharmacies 6,000 of them
we publish it every 30 seconds that's
why our Civic hackers our civil
engineers in the digital space built
more than 100 tools that enable people
to view a map or people with blindness
which talked to chat BOTS voice
assistants all of them can get the same
exclusive access to information about
which pharmacist near them still have
masks and because the national health
insurance single-payer is more than 99.9
percent of health coverage people who
show any symptom would then be able to
take the medical masks go to a local
clinic knowing fully that they would get
treated fairly without incurring any
financial burden as a people design
dashboard that lets everybody see our
supplies indeed growing and whether it
is over or under supply so that we co
designed this distribution system with
the pharmacies with the whole of society
so based on this analysis we show that
the it was a a peak as 70% and the
remaining 20% of people were often young
worked very long hours when they go off
work the pharmacists also went off work
and so we work with the convenience
store so that everybody can collect
their in mass anytime 24 hours a day so
we ensure fairness of all kinds based on
the digital democracy
feedback and finally I would like to
acknowledge that this is a very
stressful time people feel anxious
outraged there's a lot of panic buying a
lot of conspiracy theories in all
economies and in Taiwan are a counter
disinformation strategy is very simple
it's called humor over rumor so when
there was a panic buying of Tisha papers
for example there was a rumor that says
we're ramping up mass production is the
same material as tissue papers and so it
will run out of teacher Harrison and our
premier showed a very romantic picture
that I simply have to share with you in
very large print he shows his bottom
wiggling it a little bit and then the
large print says each of us only have
one pair of Botox and of course the
serious table does that shows that
official papers came from South American
materials and medical masks come from
domestic materials and there's no way
the rampion production of one will hurt
the production of the other and so it
now went absolutely viral and because of
that depend buying died down in a day or
two and finally we found out the person
who spread a rumor at the first place
was the tissue paper
Rosella and this is not just a single
shot point in social media every single
day the daily press conference gets
translated by the spokes talk of the
Ministry of Health and Welfare that
translated a lot of things for example
our physical distance saying is phrased
as saying if you're out door you need to
keep two Doga away if you're in door
three Doda away and so on and hand
sanitation rules and so on so because
all this go viral will make sure that
the factual humour spreads faster than
rumor and they serve as a vaccine as
inoculation so that when people see the
conspiracy theories that are not value
of that will be below one meaning that
those ideas will not spread and so I
only have this five minutes briefing the
rest of it will be driven by your Q&A
but please feel free to read more about
how one's character coronavirus strategy
a town can help that us thank you
that's incredible and I love this humor
versus rumor the problem here in the
u.s. perhaps
is that the the rumors seem to travel
faster than any response whether
humorous or not how do you defeat that
aspect in Taiwan now we found that of
course humor implicitly means that is
the sublimation of upsetness of outrage
and so as you see for example in our
premiers example he makes fun of himself
he doesn't make a joke at expense of
other people and this was the key
because people think it hilarious they
share it but with no malicious or toxic
intentions people remember the actual
payload that's table about materials
used to produce masks much more easily
if they make a joke that excludes parts
of the society of course that part of
society will feel outraged and we will
end up creating more divisive nough Stan
pro-social behavior so the humor that at
no expense of not you know excluding any
part of society I think that was the key
it's also incredible because Taiwan has
such close ties to the origin ER scene
of this yes the mainland so how how do
you given those close economic ties how
do you survive that kind of disruption
yeah I mean we at this moment it's been
almost a month now with no local
confirmed cases so we're doing fine and
what we're doing essentially is just to
respond faster and pretty much anyone we
started responding last year whereas
pretty much everybody else started
responding this year we try to to warn
the world last year but anyway so in any
case at the point here is that if you
start early enough you get to make sure
that the border control is the main
point where you quarantine or the
returning residents and so on instead of
waiting on to the community spread stage
where even more human right invading
techniques would probably have to be
deployed one way or the other and so
Intel we've not declared a emergency
situation where
under the constitutional law because of
that every measure the administration is
taking is also applicable in non
coronavirus times and this forces us to
innovate much as the idea of we are a
open liberal democracy prevented us from
doing takedowns and therefore we have to
innovate of humor versus rumor because
the easy path that takedown of our
speech is not accessible to us our
design criteria which is no lockdowns
also prevented us from doing any you
know very invasive privacy encroaching
response system so we have to innovate
Eddy Bhoja and make sure that we have
sufficient number of for example
quarantine hotels or so-called digital
fence where your phone is
basically connected to the nearby
telecoms and they make sure that if they
go out of the 15 meter or so radius a
SMS is sent to the local household
managers or police and so on but with
because we focus all these measures at
the border the vast majority of people
live a normal life let's let's talk
about that a little bit so walk me
through the digital tools and how they
were applied to to Kovan yes so there's
three part that is outlined the first
one is the collective intelligence
system through how in spaces that we
design to be devoid of three-ply patents
because we see that when there is reply
buttons people focus on Asia others face
part not that book part and with our
reply buttons you can get collective
intelligence working out their rough
consensus of where the direction is
going with the response strategies so we
use a lot of new technologies such as
polis which is essentially a forum that
lets you upload and download each
other's feelings but with a real-time
clustering so that if you go to Co hack
TW you see six such conversations
talking about how to protect the most
vulnerable people how to make a smooth
transition how to make a fair
distribution supplies and so on and
people are free to voice their ideas and
upload and download each other's ideas
but a trick is that we show people the
main
points and the Menken central points and
we respond only to the ideas that can
convince all the different opinion
groups so people are encouraged to post
more eclectic more nuanced ideas and
they discover at the end of this
consultation that everybody actually
agree with most of things with mostraron
neighbors on most of the issues and that
is what we call the social mandate or
the Democratic mandate that then informs
our development of the counter-current a
virus strategy and helping the world
with such tools and so this is the first
part is called listening a scale for
rough consensus the second part I
already covered is the distributed
ledger where everybody can go to a
nearby pharmacy present their nhi card
fine line mask or ten if you're a child
and see the stock level of that pharmacy
on their film actually decreasing by
nine or ten in a couple minutes and if
they grow by nine or ten of course
you're called in one night to to and
report something fishy is going on but
this is participate rip accountability
this is published every thirty seconds
so everybody held each other accountable
and that massively increased trust and
finally the third one the humor versus
rumor I think the important thing to see
here is that whenever there's a trending
disinformation or conspiracy theory you
respond to it with a humorous package
within two hours we have discovered if
we respond within two hours then more
people see the vaccination then the
conspiracy theory but if you respond
four hours or a day after what then
that's a lost cause you can't really
counter that using humor anymore you
have to invite the person who spread
those messages into co-creation
workshops but we're okay with that here
your speed is incredible
I see Whitney has joined us with some
questions that's right we have a couple
of you coming in already from the
audience hi there I'm Audrey and we'll
start with one from our community member
Michael Beck's
he asks how long has humor versus rumor
been strategy that you think that she
implemented scuse me how long has the
humor versus rumor strategy been
implemented and where comedians has
consulted to make the human yes
definitely comedians are our most
cherished
colleagues and each and every ministry
have a team of what we call
participation offices in charge of
engaging with trending topics and it's a
more than 100 people strong team now we
meet every month and also every couple
weeks on specific topics it's been like
that since late 2016
but it's not until our previous book
person cool as you dr. joined about a
year and half ago do the professional
comedians gets to the team previously
this is more about inviting the people
who post you know quotes like our text
filing system is explosively hostile and
guest trending and previously the POS
just invite those people everybody who
complain about a finance ministers text
file experience gets invited to
co-creation of the text finally
experience so previously was that Baku
SEO Dhaka and the premiere so Jen Chang
said it wouldn't it be much better and
reach more people if we add some dog to
it or cats pictures to it and that's
been around for a year and happy
definitely that I think it makes a lot
of difference just even seeing them
without being part of the thought
process behind that and we have another
question here from G Ryan Anson he asks
what would you rank the level of trust
your community had before the pandemic
in order for the government to have a
chance to properly controlling this
crisis I would say that a community
trusts each other and that is the main
point of digital democracy this is not
about people trusting the government
more this is about the government
trusting the citizens more making the
state transparent to the citizen nor the
citizen transparent to the state which
will be some other regime
so making a staged transparent
repentance doesn't always elicit more
trust because you may see something
wrong something missing something
explosively hostile to its user
experience and someone of the state so
it doesn't necessarily lead to more
trust from the government sorry it's
from the citizen to a government they
always plays to more trust between the
social sector stakeholders so I would
say the level of trust between the
people who are working on for example
medical officers and people who working
with the pandemic responses people who
manufacture medical masks and so on all
these people the trust below between
them is very high and not necessarily
they trust the government but we don't
need that for their successful response
if you ask a random person on the street
they will say you know Taiwan is
performing so well because of the people
when the CCC tell us to wear the mask we
were at a mosque when the CCC's tell us
not to wear a mask like if you are
keeping physical distance we wear a mask
anyway and so because of that I think is
the social sector
trust between those different
stakeholders that's the key to the
response I will come back shortly with
more questions but I'll leave you guys
to continue your conversation well
clearly part of that trust in in
government was maybe not there in in
2014 during the sunflower movement so
talk to me about about that and and how
that led to this kind of digital
transformation I mean if in before March
2014 if you ask a random person on the
street in Taiwan like whether it's
possible for the administer that's me to
have their office in a park literally a
park anyone can walk in and talk to me
for 40 minutes at a time I'm currently
in that Park the Social Innovation Lab
they would say that this is crazy right
no no all public officials work like
that but that was because at march 18
2014
hundreds of young activists most of them
college students occupied the
legislature to express their profound
opposition to a trade pact with Beijing
under consideration and the secretive
manner in which was pushed through the
Parliament by coming down the ruling
party at a time and so the protestor
demanded very simply that a park to be
scraped and the government instituted a
more transparent ratification process
and that drew widespread public support
it ended a little more than three weeks
later after the government promised and
agreed on the you know 40 months not one
less of legislative oversight
a poll released after the occupation
showed that more than 75% remain
dissatisfied with the ruling government
illustrating the crisis of trust that
was caused by a trade deal dispute and
to heal this rift and communicate better
with everyday citizens the
administration reach out to the people
who supported the occupiers
for example the gives 0 community g0v
which has been sneaking to improve
government transparency through the
creation of open-source tools and so
Jaclyn's high agora ministry at a time
attended our hackathon and proposed the
establishment of novel platforms with
online community to exchange policy
ideas and an experiment was born called
a vita wan that pioneer the use of tor
such as polis that allows for agree or
disagree but with no reply button that
gets people's rough consensus on issues
such as crowdfunding equity base broker
funding to be precise
teleworking and many other cyber related
legislation of which there's no existing
unions or associations and it proved to
be very successful they solve the uber
problem for example and by now you can
call uber I just call it over this week
but in any case they are operating as
taxis they set up a local taxi company
koku taxi and that was because on the
platform people cared about insurance
they care about registration they care
about all the sort of protection of the
passengers and so on so we change the
taxi regulations and now uber is just
another taxi company along with the
other coops so you're actually in a way
crowdsourcing laws that well but then
become laws yeah learn more at crowd
that's law it's a real website so some
might say that this seems easier because
Taiwan is an island that maybe helps you
control Cove it helps promote social
cohesion maybe it's a smaller country
than then some do you think that this
could be scaled beyond Taiwan well first
of all 23 million people is still quite
some people it's not
a CD as somebody usually said in Taiwan
is a city-state well
23 million people not quite a city-state
and what I'm trying to get it is that
the high population density and a
variety of cultures we have more than 20
national languages doesn't necessarily
lead to a social cohesion as is that
rather it I think this is the humbleness
of the other ministers in the conquer
coronavirus response they all took on a
attitude of so we learned about SARS
many of them were in charge of the stars
back then but that was classical
epidemiology this is stars 2.0 it has
different characteristics and the tools
that we use is very different because of
the digital transformation and so we're
in it to learn together with the
citizens our vice-president at a time
dr. Chen Jian a academician literally
wrote the textbook on epidemiology
however he still says you know what I'm
going to do is record a online MOOC a
crash course I have ideology that shares
with I think more than 20,000 people in
row the first day I was among them to
learn about important ideas like there
are not and spread basic transmission
and how the various different measures
work and then they asked people to
innovate if you think of a new way
that's the first president did not think
of just call 192 and your idea will
become the next days press conference
and this is this co-learning strategy i
think that more than anything
enabled the social cohesion as you speak
but this is a more of a robust civil
society than the uniformity there's no
uniformity at all in taiwan everybody is
entitled to their ideas and all the
social innovations ranging from using a
traditional rice cooker to revitalize to
disinfect the mosque - pink medical mask
and so on there's all variety a very
interesting idea that gets amplified by
the daily press conference that's that's
beautiful
now I'll be Whitney is back so I will
let her ask the next question sure we're
having some more questions come in one
from our community member Aria Bendix
Aria asked how do you ensure that
digital campaigns act quickly without
sacrificing accuracy in the u.s. there
was a fear of inciting panic about hope
at 19 in early January this is a great
question so most of the scientific ideas
about the COBIT it's evolving right the
efficacy of mosque for example is a very
good example because the different
characteristics of previous respiratory
diseases respond differently to the
facial mask and so our digital campaigns
focus on the idea of getting the rough
consensus true so basically is a
reflection of the society through poulos
through slider through the joint
platform the various thoughts that veto
and has prototypes we know that people
are feeling a rough consensus about
things and we're responding to the
society saying this is what you all
feels and this is what we are doing to
respond to your feelings and the
scientific consensus still developing
but we know for example people feel that
wearing a mask
mostly protect you because it reminds
you to not touch your face and wash your
hands properly and these regardless of
everything else are the two things that
everybody agrees with so we just
capitalize on that and say okay I wash
your hands properly and don't touch your
face and wear a mask reminds you of that
and that's let's discuss through the
kind of very ideologically charged
debates and focus on what people
generally resonate with one another and
that's how we act quickly without
sacrificing scientific accuracy and this
next question maybe sort of feels
connected to this as well it's a
question from an anonymous community
member do you think any of our policies
could be applied in the United States
under the current trump administration
quite a few actually we work with many
states in the US and abroad what we call
epicenter to epicenter
diplomacy well we're doing essentially
is to for example there was a chatbot in
Taiwan that lets you but especially
people under home quarantine to ask the
chat about anything and if there is a
scientific adviser who already wrote a
frequently asked question the chat pod
just respond with that but otherwise
they will call their science advisory
board and write a accessible response to
that and the spokesdog will translate
that into cute dog meme
and so this feedbacks cycle of people
very easily accessing finding and ask a
scientist and a open api that allows for
voice assistance and other third party
developers to to get through it
resonates with many US states and i
think many of them are implementing it
and before the World Health Assembly I
think three days before we held a 14
countries merely a lateral meeting kind
of pre whi where we shared many small
like quick wins like this and I think
many jurisdictions some of that
including the humor versus rumor many of
them said that they're going to recruit
comedians now I also - and we have one
more question which is actually a
follow-up from Michael Beck's who asked
a question earlier does the ministry
plan to publish their plans in a white
paper which sounds like you're already
sharing your plans with folks but do you
have a plan yet out yes on a paper of
course yeah and multiple white papers so
if you go to how and can help that us
that is where most of our strategies and
that website is actually across those as
well and issues at the more than five
million now I think medical mask donated
to the humanitarian aid is also across
some people who have some masks in their
home who did not collect the rationed
masks they can use an app say I want to
dedicate this to international
humanitarian aid and we publish have
them and choose to publish their names
so you can also see the names of people
who participate this and there's also a
asked I want anything web
at fight code that edu that PW got
outlines or the in white paper form
called response strategies so check
those out great
well I will disappear me back later with
some questions other questions a
blizzard of white papers if you will I'd
like to turn the focus on on you a
little bit how does a conservative
anarchists become a digital minister by
occupying the Parliament we and through
that but more interestingly I say that I
go working with the government but never
for the government and I work with the
people not for two people I like Eddie
this Lagrange point between the people's
movements on one side and the government
on the other side sometimes right in the
middle trying to do some culture
translation work some time in a kind of
triangle point trying to supply both
sides with at was for pro-social
communication but always with this idea
of getting the shared values out of
different positions are the varied
positions because all too often
democracy is billed as a showdown
between opposing values but in the
pandemic in the info demmick in climate
change in many of those structural
issues that virus or carbon dioxide
doesn't sit down and negotiate with you
right it's a structural issue that
requires common values builds out of
different positions and so that is why
my working principle is radical
transparency every conversation
including this one is on the record
including the internal meetings that I
held so you can see all the different
meeting transcripts in my youtube
channel in the stated my forum where
people can see after I become digital
Minister I held 1,300 meetings with more
than 5,000 speakers was more than 206
60,000 utterances and each every of them
has a URL that become a social object
that people can have a conversation on
and because of that for example when
ubers David Plouffe
visited me to to lobby for uber because
of radical transparency he is very much
aware of that and so he make all the
arguments based on probably good based
on sustainability and things like that
because he know that the others eyes
will see his positions very clearly and
transparently
and so that encourages people to add on
each other's argument instead of
attacking each others person you know
credits and things like that and so I
think that's more than anything is the
main principle of conserving the
anarchism of the Internet which is about
you know nobody can force anyone to hook
to the internet or to adhere to a new
Internet Protocol everything has to be
done using rough consensus and running
code I wish you had more counterparts
all around the world maybe you wish you
had more counterparts all around the
world that's why these ideas are worth
spreading there you go so one of the
challenges that that might arise with
some of these digital tools is is access
how do you approach that part of it for
folks maybe who don't have the best
broadband connection or the latest
mobile phone or whatever or whatever it
might be that's required well anywhere
in Taiwan even on the top of Taiwan
almost 4,000 meters high to Savia or the
Jade Mountain you're guaranteed to have
ten megabits per second over 4G or fiber
or people with just 16 US dollars a
month unlimited plan and actually on the
top of the mountain it's faster fewer
people use that bandwidth and if you
don't it's my fault it's personally my
fault in Taiwan we have broadband as a
human right and so when we're deploying
5g we're looking at places where the 4G
has the weakest signal and we're
beginning with those places in our 5g
deployment and only by deploying
broadband as a human right can we say
that's this is for everybody that there
so democracy is actually strengthens
democracy otherwise we will be excluding
parts of the society and this also
applies to for example you can go to a
local digital Opportunity Center to rent
a tablet as warranty to be manufacturing
the past three years and
like that to enable all sort of
different digital access by the dish to
opportunity centers universities and
schools and public libraries very
important and if people who prefer to
talk in their Town Hall I personally go
to that town hall and with the 360
recorder and live streamed ads to Taipei
and to other municipalities where the
central government public servants can
join in the connected room style but
listening to local people who said
agenda so people still do face-to-face
meetings we're not doing this to replace
witch's face meetings we're bringing
more stakeholders from central
government in the local town halls and
we're amplifying their voices by making
sure their transcripts the mind maps and
things like that are spread through the
internet during real time but we don't
ever ask our elderly to say oh you have
to learn talking otherwise you don't do
democracy it's not our style but there
requires problem because if you don't
have problem but only a very limited
bandwidth you're forced to use text
based communication that's right well
with access of course comes access for
folks who who maybe will misuse the
platform you talk a little bit about
disinformation and using humor to beat
rumor but but sometimes disinformation
is more is more weaponized how do you
combat those kinds of attacks
really right so you mean well
information then so yeah actually
information designed to cost intentional
public harm and that's right and decimal
that's no laughing matter so for that we
have a idea called notice in public
notice so this is a Reuters photo and I
will read the original caption the
original caption says a teenage
extraction bill protester in Hong Kong
is seen during a March to demand
democracy and political reform in Hong
Kong okay a very neutral title by
droites but there was a spreading of a
mole information back last November just
leading to our presidential election
that shows something else entirely
this has the same photo but says this 13
year old sock bought new iPhones game
console and brand names for shoes in
recruiting his brothers to
murder police and collect two thousand
two hundred thousand dollars and this of
course is a weapon designed to sow
discord and to illicit in Taiwanese
voters a kind of distaste for Hong Kong
and because they know that this is at
the main issue and had we resort to
takedowns that will not work because
that will only evoke more outrage so we
didn't do a takedown instead we work
with the fact checkers and professional
journalists to attribute this original
message back to the first day that it
was posted and it came from Jones and
Poway chimes in that is the main
political and legal unit of the Central
Party in the central communities party
in CCP and we know that is their Weibo
account that first did this new caption
so we've send out a public notice and
with the partnering social media
companies pretty much all of them they
just put this very small reminder next
to each time that this is shared with
the wrong caption that says this
actually came from the central
propaganda unit of the CCP click here to
learn more to learn about the whole
story and that we found that has worked
because people understand this is then
not a in news material this is rather
appropriation of Reuters news material
and a copyright infringement at night I
think that's part of the trade deal in
any case the point is that when people
understand that this is an international
narrative they won't just randomly share
it they may share it but with a comment
that says oh this is what the you know
Georgia Highway is trying to do to our
democracy seems like some of the global
social media companies could could learn
something from notice and public notice
what what what what advice would you
have for the Twitter's and Facebook's
and lines and whatsapp's and you name of
the world mm-hmm
yeah so just before our election we said
to all of them that were not making a
law to kind of punish them
however we're sharing this very simple
fact that there is a norm in Taiwan that
we even have a separate branch of the
government the control branch that
published the campaign donation and
expense and it just so occurred to us
that in the previous election the mayor
or one there's a lot of candidate that
did not include any social media
advertisement in their expense to the
control UN and so essentially that means
that there is a separate amount of
political donation and expense that
evades public scrutiny and our control
Ian's published their numbers in raw
data for those who say no statistics but
individual records of who donated for
what cause when where and investigative
journalists is very happy because they
can then make investigative reports
about the connections between the
candidates and the people who fund them
but they cannot work with the same
material from the global social media
companies so I said look this is very
simple this is a social norm here I
don't really care about other
jurisdictions you either adhere to the
social norm that is set by the control
UN and the investigative journalists or
maybe you will face social sanction and
this is not the government mandate that
is the people fed up with you know black
box and that's part of a sample are
occupy demand also and so Facebook
actually published in the ads library I
think at that time one of the fastest
and response strategy where everybody
who basically have any dark pattern
advertisement will get reviewed very
quickly and the investigative
journalists work with the local civic
technologists to make sure that if
anybody dare to use social media in such
a divisive way within an hour there will
be a report out condemning that so
nobody try that during the previous
presidential election season so change
is possible
mm-hmm you know we have some more
questions from the community there is an
anonymous woman that says I believe
Taiwan is outside of the World Health
Organization entirely it has a 130 part
preparation program developed entirely
it's owned to what extent does it credit
its preparation to building its own
system well a little bit I guess we
tried to warn the whu-oh but at that
point we're not totally outside we have
limited scientific access that we do not
have any ministry or access and this is
very different right if you only have
limited scientific access unless the
other sites pop it up ideologist happens
to be the vice president
like intimates case that they don't
always do the storytelling well enough
to translate that into political action
SR vice president did right so the lack
of ministerial access I think is to the
detriment to the global community
because otherwise people could have
responded as we did in the first day of
January instead of having to wait for
weeks before that whu-oh declared that
this is something that is definitely
human to human transmission that you
should inspect people coming in from
Wuhan which they eventually did but
that's already two weeks or three weeks
after what we did were scientists more
scientists and technologists and
politics that's that sounds like that's
the answer and then we have another
question here from Kamal Srinivasan
about URI reopening strategy are you
enabling how are you enabling
restaurants and retailers to open safely
in Taiwan what they never closed so um
so we never closed there there was no no
lockdown there was no closure
we just said a very simple thing in the
ccc press conference that there's going
to be a physical distancing you maintain
one-and-a-half meters indoors or wear a
mask and does it and so there's some
restaurants that put out I guess red
curtains some put very cute teddy bears
and so on on the chairs to make sure
that people spread evenly some installed
plastic see-through glass or plastic
walls between the seats there's various
social innovations happening around and
I think the only
shops that got closed for a while
because they they could not innovate
quick enough to respond to these rules
was the intimate escort bars but
eventually even they invented new ways
by handing out these caps that are
plastic shielding but still leaves room
for drinking behind it and so they open
with that social innovation that's
amazing sound like it's a lot to to
learn from from your strategies there
thank you I'll be back late towards the
end to some final questions I think I'm
very happy to hear that the restaurants
were not closed down because I think
Taipei had some of the best food in the
world of any city that I've that I've
visited so you know kudos to you for
that
so the the big concern when it comes to
using digital tools for Cova door or
using digital tools for democracy is
always privacy you've you've talked
about that a little bit I'm sure the
citizens of Taiwan are or perhaps
equally concerned about their privacy
especially given the geopolitical
context so how do you how do you cope
with those demands mm-hmm yeah we design
was not only a defensive strategy like
minimization of data collection but also
proactive measures such as privacy
enhancing technologies one of the top
team that emerge out of our Co hack the
TWU response of death from the police on
how to make contact tracing easier
focused not under contact tracers
not under the medical offices but on the
person so they basically said okay you
have a phone you can record your
temperatures you can you know record
your whereabouts and things like that
but that's straightly in your phone it
doesn't even use bluetooth so there's no
transmission technology uses open stalls
you can check it you can use it in
airplane mode and when the contact
tracer eventually tell you that you're a
part of a high-risk group
and they really want your contact
history this tool can then generate a
single-use URL that only contains the
precise information anonymized data
contact tracers want but it will not
like in a traditional interview let you
you know ask they ask a question only
want to know your whereabouts that you
answer with such accuracy that you end
up compromising other people's privacy
so basically this is about designing
with a aim to enhance other people's
privacy because personal data is never
truly personal it's always social it's
always intersectional if I take a selfie
at a party I inadvertently also take
pretty much everybody else's who are in
the picture the surroundings the
ambience and so on if I upload it to a
cloud service then I actually estimate
the bargaining power the negotiation
power of everybody around me because
then their data is part of the cloud in
a cloud doesn't have to compensate them
or get their agreement for it and so
only by designing the tools who is a
privacy enhancing as a positive value
and not enhancing only the person's own
privacy just like medical mask it
protects you but mostly it also protects
others right so if we design to us using
that idea and always open-source and
with an open API then we're in a much
better shape than in a centralized or
so-called cloud-based services well
you're clearly living in the future and
I guess that's quite literal in the
sense of tomorrow in there yes but yeah
tell me tell me what do you see in the
future what what comes next
mmm-hmm yes so I see the corona virus is
a great amplifier if you start with
authoritarian society the corona virus
was always locked down since the one I
have the potential of making it even a
more totalitarian society if people
place their trust however on the social
sector on the ingenuity of social
innovators then the pandemic as in
Taiwan actually strengthened
our democracy so that people feel truly
that everybody can think of something
that improves the welfare of not just
high one but pretty much everybody else
in the world and so my point here is
that the great amplifier comes no matter
you want it or not but the society what
they can do is what do what I want did
after SARS in 2003 when Soros came we
had to shut down an entire Hospital
barricading it with no definite
termination date it was very traumatic
everybody above the age of 30 remembers
how traumatic it was the municipalities
and the central government was saying
very different things
and and that is why after SARS the
Constitutional Court's charged the
legislature to set up the system as you
see today and also that is why when
people responding to death crisis back
in 2003 build this very robust response
system that there's ear lead drills so
just as the sunflower occupy because of
the crisis in trust let us build new
tools that puts trust first
I think the coronavirus is the chance
for everybody who have survived through
the first wave to settle on a new set of
norms that will reinforce your founding
values instead of taking on alien values
in the name of survival let's let's hope
so and let's hope we're where the rest
of the world is as prepared as Taiwan
the next time around when it comes to
digital democracy though and digital
citizenship where do you see that going
both in Taiwan and maybe in the rest of
the world well I have my job description
here which I will read to you it's
literally my job description and the
answer to that question and so here goes
when we see the internet of things let's
make an Internet of beans we see virtual
reality let's make it a shared reality
we see machine learning let's make it
collaborative learning we see user
experience let's make it about human
experience
and whenever we hear the singularity is
near that has always remember a
plurality is here thank you for
listening
Wow I have to I have to give that a
little clap that was beautiful that was
quite a job description too so
conservative AG anarchist to digital
Minister and with that job description
that's pretty impressed a polar
politician so I struggle to imagine a
adoption of these techniques in the US
and that maybe my pessimism weighing in
but what words of hope do you have for
the US as we as we cope with kovat well
as I mentioned during SARS in Taiwan
nobody imagined we could have a CCC an
acute spokesdog
before the sunflower movement during
their large protest was if I think half
a million people on the street and many
more nobody thought that we could have a
collective intelligence system that puts
open government data as a way to reap
uses and participation and so never lose
hope as my favorite singer Linda Cohen
poet also it's fun to say ring the bells
that still can ring and forget any
perfect offering there's a crack in
everything and that is how the light
gets in that's so beautiful and I it it
feels like such a great message to sort
of leave the audience with and sharing
the sentiment that everyone seems to be
so grateful for what you've shared
Audrey and all the the great information
and insight into Taiwan's strategies and
David did too I was just gonna say thank
you so much for that thank you for that
beautiful job description and for all
the wisdom you shared in rapid-fire
fashion I think it wasn't just one idea
that you shared but maybe I don't know
20 30 40 I lost count at some point well
it's called idea
we're sprinting is the plural form very
true well thank you so much for joining
us and what's everything thank you and
have a good local time stay safe